easy does it is a freewheeling adventure
comedy about two friends Jack and Scotty
robbing their way to San Clemente along
the way they form an unlikely friendship
with their hostage Colin with their
adversaries in hot pursuit they learn
that changing dreams isn't always easy
the hardest part of making an indie film
without a doubt is getting it financed
in order to raise the budget we needed
to make this movie we started putting
together this package for investors to
see we made a promotional concept
trailer which would show them kind of
the vibe and style and tone of the movie
we wrote very extensive business plan
illustrating the potential returns the
film could gain you know comparing it to
other previous similar films these folks
who are potentially interested in
investing wanted to see that they're
going to get a return and the way that
you do that is show them that the film
will get a distribution we live in this
great age where all of a sudden there's
a lot of ways to get your movie out
there it's no longer you know in
theaters or straight to video the way
that you show them that they'll get
distribution can be one of several
things either it's a genre that really
sells well like horror or as with us you
try to attach name actors name actors
can really kind of be the difference
between an equally good movie getting
lost in the clutter and getting you know
either decent or very good distribution
and people actually seeing the thing and
that they making money the catch-22 with
that is that they kind of need to know
that you're serious and that often means
having the collateral having the budget
there to say hey I can put my money
where my mouth is so now your comments
catch-22 right where I like the
investors are like oh yeah and I like
your script i'll invest if so-and-so
comes on and meanwhile the actor system
that's it you know i like the role i'll
come on if you for sure have the club
know how the capital have the budget to
sign our actors we were going to need to
figure out a way to come up with some
seed funding so to help get this movie
made we recently launched a kickstarter
campaign this film's a big
stepping-stone for our careers and we
hope you'll come along for the ride
thanks for watching and you can check
out our kickstarter in the link below